now the ever struggling joe biden was
caught in yet another bizarre moment
this week
after claiming he used to drive an
18-wheeler semi-truck
take a look anyway
and if we don't drive an 18-wheeler man
the only problem there's no evidence he
ever did
with the white house claiming that biden
did ride
in an 18-wheeler back in 1973
but of course it gets even worse as
biden this week confused
donald trump and barack obama and
couldn't quite remember
the three reasons he ran for president
in the first place
take a look i said i was running
for three reasons one to restore the
soul of this country a sense of decency
and honor
but secondly to rebuild the backbone of
the country
hard-working middle-class folks
who built this country
the president asked me to be in charge
of managing that peace then president
trump
excuse me freudian slip that was the
last president
he caused anyway that was president
obama when i was vice president
joining me now for reaction fox news
contributors ari fleischer and
charlie hurt all right ariel i'll start
with you
uh do you believe the president when he
said he used to drive an
18-wheeler
[Laughter]
he also used to be a track driver a race
car driver too right look judge i mean
the problem here is when when he's not
plagiarizing
he's lying about himself and he's been
doing it forever
i just pulled this up it's so easy to
find he was arrested in south africa
don't forget that
he finished in the top half of his law
school class got three undergraduate
degrees got an academic scholarship
he said all that none of that is true he
claimed he was the first in family to go
to college
that's not true he said and this is
he said it on the word of abiden that he
pinned a silver star on a navy
captain in kunar province but the
captain didn't want it
none of that not one sentence in that
was
true and he also said he got a start at
a historical black
college or university delaware state he
didn't go there
yeah well hannah is a serial liar about
himself and the press just kind of
laughs along with him
well and you know the thought of this
guy sitting down uh charlie with
xi jinping or sitting down with putin
and i mean he doesn't even know what
he's talking about what do you think
those guys are thinking when they're
sitting across the room from him
well i think that they're probably very
relieved that they're dealing with this
guy
now instead of the last guy uh but i
also kind of wonder if
you know after four years of one of the
most consequential presidents we've ever
had in
modern times it's almost like the swamp
is back
to sort of make the argument that it
doesn't matter who's president
you even this guy can be president
because he says the dumbest things
and for some reason it doesn't matter
but as you point out it does matter
when he does sit down with the leaders
of china or russia or or the european
union
any of these places it does matter and
it's an embarrassment
but here's the the real thing that i
think is very strange about
about joe biden joe biden has been at
this for 50 years
he's been in politics for 50 years he's
been running his mouth for 50 years
he's been running for president for most
of that time and he's
really bad at it he's terrible at it he
doesn't know whether he drove an
18-wheeler
the white house said well it was a
school bus if the guy doesn't know the
difference between driving a
18-wheeler and a school bus i mean
how how would you let this guy be in
charge of anything
but then he says things like you know
the the freudian
he doesn't even know what a freudian
slip is and then
and then and it's like the most basic
thing
when you start off to list three
things you're supposed to always list
three
things and that's my point he's so
bad at it what he he should have gotten
out a long time ago
well you know and the shame of it is you
know when he's talking about those three
things he says when you know he got
into the race nobody thought he could
win well i guess that the plan was that
he would win and so ariel go to you i
mean you've trained enough politicians
worked with enough of them that you know
those three reasons that you give like
the first question why do you want to
run for president why do you want him
for governor why do you want to run for
this
i mean you know the guy doesn't pass the
basic fundamentals
and yet no one in the media cares i know
because the media is in with them
what what's your take on him well this
is what bothers me so much we we do see
a president who is about to turn 79 and
legitimate questions should be raised
about
how he's doing how his mental health is
how his acuity is
you watch him in the in his speech in
the news conference today
he can be sharp there's no question
about it he can go back and forth with
reporters and hear their questions and
give
lucid answers to it but when he
constantly gets things wrong too
there should be a scrutiny the press
should cover it but the mainstream media
has just seen fit to give him a total
pass
they don't hold him to account when he
makes up all these lies about himself
they kind of just chuckle they'll note
it maybe in passing once
and then move on to the next pro-biden
story that they write
this is the problem too why do they have
to protect and cover for him
instead of criticize him and draw
attention
to his frailties the way they would for
any other president and
you know charlie the the whole idea of
joe biden coming up and
coming out and saying that what he wants
is he wants you know he's building back
better and everything is great again
you know he he blames everything on
trump that he doesn't think is good just
like obama blamed everything on bush
i don't ever remember the republican
presidents doing this blaming them on
the democrats before them although i
could be wrong i don't know
but you know when joe biden comes out
and says you know i'm not supposed to
i'm not supposed to take any more
questions or i'm not supposed to answer
that
he still can't stop saying that so they
must spank him or something
when he goes back from a press
conference
well that that's the one part about
being a politician he's very good at
he's very good at blaming other people
for his mistakes
but ari puts his finger on something
that's very important here
the fact that he can be lucid sometimes
is
is almost more problematic because you
don't know whether you're getting
lucid joe biden or completely insane joe
biden
and that and that makes it in a lot of
ways even more frightening
because it raises the question okay so
if if he can if he's all over the place
in terms of his
mental abilities and and his ability to
sort of uh be
with it then who's actually in charge
when he does lose his mind
is there somebody there and and who is
that person
we this is a free country where we elect
our leaders
and that means we get to know we get to
pick our leaders
and we know who's in charge and right
now we have no idea
who's in charge when he's behind closed
doors eating ice cream
and talking about a fantasy of
driving an 18-wheeler or whatever it is
it's pretty alarming
yeah and and also alarming is how does
he go from being so
discombobulated to being loosened you
know
what happens to get him right ari
fleischer and charlie hurt thanks so
much for being with us tonight
and hi everyone i'm brian kilmeade i
want you to do me a favor i want you to
click to subscribe to the fox news
youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great
news bites any great interviews coming
your way on fox you can get it all here
on youtube so subscribe right now